Merhaba ben Onat Dursun pek konuşmama
başlamadan önce Sürdürülebilir
kalkınmanın ne olduğundan bahsetmek
istiyorum ki daha rahat anlaşılayım
sürdürülebilir kalkınma dünyamıza daha
iyi davranarak hem kendimiz için hem de
gelecek nesiller için daha güzel bir
gelecek bırakmaya çalışmaktır
Bizler Z kuşağı olarak belki bu hayat
denen arenada yeniyiz fakat
büyüklerimizin daha yeni yeni fark
etmeye başladığı konuları Biz
bezlerimizi çıkarttıktan 7-8 yıl sonra
fark etmeye başladık büyüklerimiz için
çevreyi korumaya çalışanlar yanlış
anlamazsın yeşil ekonomi veya
sürdürülebilir kalkınma dendiği zaman
çok bir anlam ifade etmese de biz
gençler ve geleceğimiz için çok şey
ifade ediyor
Ben Sait faik'in Son Kuşlar adlı
öyküsünün son paragrafı okumak istiyorum
konumuza bağlantılı
dünya değişiyor dostlarım günün birinde
gökyüzünde güz mevsiminde artık esmer
lekeler göremeyeceksiniz
günün birinde yol kenarlarında Toprak
anamızın koyu yeşil saçlarını da
göremeyeceksiniz bizim için değil ama
çocuklar sizin için kötü olacak Biz
kuşları ve yeşillikleri çok gördük sizin
için kötü olacak benden hikayesi demiş
Sait Faik Peki bu paragrafa baktığımızda
hangi Duygu daha iyi uyumlu hangi
duyguyu daha yoğunluklu görüyoruz endişe
dediğinizi duyar gibiyim peki ne ile
alakalı bir endişe duyuyor
gelecek nesillerle alakalı geleceğimizle
alakalı bir endişe duyuyor değil mi İşte
biz bu endişeye Eko anksiyet ediyoruz
doğamızın geleceğiyle alakalı gelecek
nesillerin geleceği ile alakalı duyulan
endişeye ekonsiyet ediyoruz Peki biz bu
Eko anksiyeti örneklendirecek olursak ne
diyebiliriz mesela YouTube'da bilimsel
videolar izlerken geleceğimizle alakalı
bilimsel videolar izlerken oradaki
konuşmacılar karar verici gibi
dünyamızda şunlar olacak bu hayvanların
nesli tükenecek dendiği zaman ya zaten
daha kötüydü daha da mı kötü olacak
dediğimizde İşte o Duygu anksiyet oluyor
gelecek nesiller için duyduğumuz endişe
sürdürülebilirlik zaten uzun süredir
dünyamızın gündeminde olan bir konuydu
fakat
yaklaşık 2020'den sonra gelişen
olaylardan sonra salgın olsun doğal
felaketler olsun bu olayların
fazlalaşmasıyla daha da fazla gündeme
gelmeye başladı
Peki
sürdürülebilir kalkınma için tamam mı
yoksa devam mı
ben tamam mı Ya da devam mı derken bana
zarar veren şeylerden kurtulmak için
tamam
devam derken de yanlışlarından öğrenip
yanlışlarımı doğruya çevrilmemek için
devam derim Peki ben sürdürülebilir
kalkınma için ne derim
doğamızı Kirletmeye devam mı
ağaçları katletmeye devam mı ozon
tabakasını delmeye devam mı temiz kokmak
için dağdıran sıkmaya bir gün geldiğinde
bir bardak suyla yıkanmayı göze almaya
tamam mı yoksa devam mı Bence Tamam
yeter artık dünyamıza yeteri kadar zarar
verdik
fakat buna karşılık olarak Bazı konuları
aynı zamanda devam ediyorum
dünyamızı daha güzelleştirecek daha
güzel bir gelecek bırakacak doğanay'a
hürmet edeceğimiz her şeye devam Peki
biz ne yapacağız da Doğan'a hürmet
edeceğiz Daha güzel bir gelecek
bırakacağız
fosil yakıtlar günümüzde çoğu yerde de
karşımıza çıkıyor ısınmadan otomobillere
kadar
bizim yapmamız gerekense nükleer
santralleri Nükleer santraller ve fosil
yakıtlara kullanmayabiliriz
onun yerine güneş panelleri veya rüzgar
gülleri kullanabiliriz Ama bunlar
bizlerin İlk Anda yapamayacağı büyük
işler Peki biz ne yapabiliriz bir renk
olarak daha az enerji tüketebiliriz
eminim hepimiz stadyumları görmüşüzdür
çok güzel bir atmosfer ışıl ışıl Fakat
bu atmosfer evimize pek yakışmıyor ışıl
ışıl olması tüm ışıkların açık olması
hem dünyamıza yakışmıyor hem de bizlere
ve gelecek nesillere yakışmıyor Bizim
yapabileceğimiz ise işimiz bittikten
sonra odamızdan çıkarken ışığımızı
kapatabiliriz böyle yapıp Hani ev
ekonomisine hem de ülke ekonomisine
katkı sağlamış olursunuz
gideceğimiz her yere arabayla değil de
yürüyerek veya bisikletle gidebilirsiniz
hem Spor yapmış olursunuz Daha su
tüketip daha su harcayabiliriz
dünyamızın yüzde yetmişi su ile kaplı bu
aranın %98'i ise
okyanuslardaki tuzlu su alıyor Peki bize
ne kadar bir oran kalıyor yüzde 0.5 hiç
de yeterli bir Oran değil değil mi
Peki biz ne yapacağız da bu arana sahip
çıkacağız bu oranı koruyacağız veya daha
fazlalaştırabiliriz
traş olurken
dişlerimizi fırçalarken suyu
kapatabiliriz
her ne kadar şu kış aylarında Sıcak su
çok rahatlatıcı olsa da duş süremizi
kısaltabiliriz daha az kağıt
tüketebiliriz
Kağıt endüstrisinin dünya üzerindeki en
çok enerji tüketen endüstrilerden biri
olduğunu biliyor muydunuz Yani demem o
ki yaygın bilginin aksine Kağıt
tüketimini azaltmakla sadece ağaç
kesilmesine değil aynı zamanda daha az
enerji tüketilmesine katkıda sağlamış
olursunuz peki biz ne yapacağız
daha işimiz biten kağıtları işimizin
bittiği kağıtları çöplere yerlere değil
de geri dönüşüm kutularına atabiliriz
veya bitirdiğimiz kitapları ihtiyaç
sahiplerine verebilir veya kütüphanelere
bağışlayabiliriz tek kullanımlık
ürünleri azaltabiliriz bunu yapmamız
gereken Bunu tam zıttı tek kullanımlık
olmayan ve geri dönüştürülebilir şeyleri
kullanmalıyız geri dönüştürülebilir
ürünleri kullanmalıyız
dijital tasarruf yapabiliriz
attığımız maillerden aldığımız dosyalara
kadar her şey enerji tüketiyor Nasıl
yani diyebilirsiniz bilgisayarınızda
bulunan veriler dosyalar mailler her şey
bulutta birikiyor ve bulutta biriktiği
için haliyle daha fazla enerji tüketiyor
biz ne yapacağız yani bu Klişe oldu
artık benim şu an söylediğim tavsiyeler
biz bu küçük tavsiyeleri uygulayarak
büyük değişimlere yol açabiliriz artık
Vatan sadece ülkemiz değil aynı zamanda
doğamız attığımız adama düşünerek atmalı
düşünmeliyiz ayağımızın altında yatan
doğanay'ı
Şimdi soruyorum size tamam mı yoksa
devam mı Teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]